il
piton saint leu en plein milieu de la
nuit
quatre fois par semaine grégory prend sa
fourgonnette pour se rendre marché du
jour ils les forains de père en fils le
nom fora désigne une personne
travaillant dans les foires et les fêtes
foraines
mais l'adjectif haut-rhin désigne par
extension une activité dans l'exercice
et mobiles et change de site au gré de
l'entreprise ce qui colle bien aux
marchands de la réunion qui vendent
leurs produits sur les marchés forains 4
heures du matin sur la plage du marché
forain de saint gilles grégory se met au
travail en décharge les marchandises
ranger dans son camion depuis la veille
bon je vais aller là vraiment c'est un
bon lever de bonne heure le matin un bon
café
or mettre debout et au marché a déjà
près par le camion depuis hier et la
dirait que
et au marché pour mater 15h40 pour ce
marché là parce que c'est un marché que
les gens n'arrivent pas trop de bonheur
donc permettre à l'avenir plus tard
habituellement troisième matin un poste
où la jeune et le plus dure 3 heures du
matin jusqu'à 6 heures le soir journée
continue
et même si pour ce marché les clients
arrivent vers 9 heures il est coutume
d'arriver très tôt le projet déjà battu
à lever grand matin faut bien il faut
bien levé si on veut travailler pour soi
même
rené c'est soit ça soulève un peu plus
tard c'est un vrai patron et c'est pas
la même vie un vrai patron qu'il le
devient tous les jours les stresser le
soleil se lève sur les plages de saint
gilles et grégory commence à servir ses
clients les plus matinaux
ah non
c'est un gel les clients sont un peu
tard actifs les gens arriver un nouvel
mis dix heures le métier de forain il a
appris avec son père ancien agriculteur
et forains pourtant ces études
conduisait vers une autre voie
comme étudiant a fait un marquez au
début ensuite un bts informatique
réseaux industriels pour les services
techniques bts iris au tampon d'après le
temps jeunes diplôm comme mon père avait
un terrain agricole de 7 hectares qu'il
fallait que
reprenez le terrain par rapport à la
safer comme terrain terrain en friche
donc on la retourne à main levée à
l'agriculture que l'armée n'a - au
marché forain comme ça une carrière dans
l'informatique le saint leusien préféré
le contact avec la population et la
tradition ma préférée la vente et en
détail au marché forain pour 1 à 3 chez
que client une discussion commence à un
moment il faut avoir le sourire tout le
temps fervent de la lafa voir sourire
c'est une bonne ambiance un bon
mouvement
c'est convivial les gens sont en plus ou
moins l'un et l'autre moyen terme avec
tout le monde par un travail un peu mon
nez à la peau travail et ne pas la peine
de s'énerver pour disputer pour
critiquer le bazar de l'un et l'autre
chacun de nos travailleurs
ah oui c'est bien moi personnellement
notamment bien que tout le monde
même si ce n'est pas l'heure de pointe
les badauds se font de plus en plus
rares le marché de saint gilles est
quasi désert certains marchands met en
cause la crise requins d'autres pointent
du doigt surtout les grandes surfaces
pour parler à deux trois années de cinq
ans de travail aux marges forêt y avait
une bonne vente le bon déroulement
maintenant il ya moins de clients - 2
- de vente ne va pas dire de bêtises au
hasard mais parce que c'est les grandes
surfaces qui fait des grands l'étalagé
tout connaît les gens arrivent la vente
surface
et pas besoin de paix longtemps pour
bord de sa voiture l'arrivée franck
surface et fait ses courses et acheter
ses fruits et légumes tout en même temps
le prix à quelques centimes près à la
fin de la matinée c'est bientôt l'heure
de tout remballer l'occasion pour
grégory de faire un petit bilan
comme en ce moment singer la prime
beaucoup nous reviendra quand même la
semaine prochaine
mais l'important n'est ce pas de faire
un métier qu'on aime et si en plus cela
nous donne le sourire et nous met de
bonne humeur
alors là on a tout gagné
et